عن الاداره العسكريه في كيا باصابه مدني
والعثور على شظايا سته صواريخ روسيه في
ثلاثه مناطق متفرقه من العاصمه
ايضا حسان السلطات كانت قد قالت بالضبط ان
الصواريخ التي اطلقت هي من طراز اسكندر
نعم يا اجري الحديث
عن اسكندر ام واسكندر كا هذه وفق المعطيات
الاوليه والمتحدث باسم الاداره او عفوا
القوات الجويه يقول ان هذه الصواريخ هي من
طراز اسكندر وانها معدله لديها تعديلات
مختلفه تؤدي بذلك الى ان تصل بسرعه كبيره
وفق تعبيره الى اهدافها او الى المواقع
التي تريد ان تصيبها وهو ما حدث بالفعل
هذا اليوم هذه هي المعطيات الاوليه الان
كما نشاهد سيتم التعامل مع هذا الصاروخ مع
حطام الصاروخ من قبل
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
وهو الاجراء المعتمد
في هذه الحالات
ستتم ايضا دراسه هذا الصاروخ كما يجري مع
عدد كبير من الصواريخ لمعرفه طبيعه
الصاروخ نوع الصاروخ التعديلات ربما التي
جرت عليه وكذلك
يتم الاحتفاظ به في مكان مخصص للاحتفاظ
الصواريخ ودراستها بشكل متكرر نعم نشاهد
الان كيف
تقوم
القوات
الاوكرانيه بازاله حطام هذا الصاروخ الذي
سقط هنا
في العاصمه الاوكرانيه خلال هذه الهجمه
المكثفه التي تعرضت لها المدينه في اطار
تصاعدي وتيره الهجمات التي تستهدف العاصمه
الاوكرانيه خلال الايام الاخيره وتحديدا
منذ بدايه شهر مايو بشكل غير مسبوق
بعدد من الوسائل والاساليب التي ايضا هي
اساليب ووسائل مختلفه اذا تمت ازاله حطام
الصواريخ وما زالت ايضا الفرق تعمل في هذا
المكان
هي من بين عدد من الضربات نعم
حتى الان المعلومات الاوليه التي افصحت
عنها الاداره العسكريه هي اصابه مدني على
الاقل عاده زين لا تفصح السلطات
الاوكرانيه عن
ضحايا عسكريين ولذلك ما يجري الحديث عنه
الان هو حديث عن اصابه مدني فقط في هذه
الضربه
هذه المعطيات هي المعطيات الاوليه حتى ان
ايضا الاداره العسكريه اكدت ان حطام لسته
صواريخ وجدت في ثلاثه او في ثلاث مناطق